[Musique]
le monde selon ma mobylette
au mexique donc derrière moi c'est
l'atlantique elle est un peu froide tout
droit à 500 km il ya le pacifique je
vais traverser principalement la région
du chiapas et maintenant mon truc je
trouve une mobylette
[Musique]
je suis ici à villahermosa qu'est la
ville un peu importante la plus proche
de la côte atlantique et c'est là où je
suis susceptible de trouver une
mobylette mais le problème je crois
c'est que les jeunes mexicains ils
veulent pas roulé en mobylette ils
veulent rouler en gros 4 4 japonais ou
grosse américaine
est elle paulo guerrero s'est d'ailleurs
je pense le poulet voyageurs à ça ce
serait extra c'est ça j'en ai cru qu il
faut
je fais une via jo de mexico comme
alors alors voilà
l état vous cette mobylette oui si et
je veux acheter une mobylette vous la
venderesse
non ici on vend des poulets rôtis pas
des mobylettes
à
je veux acheter une mobylette d'occasion
mossad à
ces possibles laquelle celle là à celles
annoncées pour mon travail assez du
travail et art ok gracias je vais
faire le monde selon k 1 trottinette le
monde selon mes chaussettes ou je ne
sais plus quoi
j'ai compris un truc en fait là où je me
plantais c'est qu'il faut que j'aille
dans les magasins d'électroménager pour
trouver une mobylette ce qui est pas
évident mais voilà comme ça là
voilà
peut-être qu'ils en ont ici
bon bah c'est du 9 1
s'il vous plaît vous me la faites à
combien cette mobylette je vous la fais
à 7200 pesos
7 milles cette nuit là les 7200 près
société mills à 7200 pesos
bon je les payais un petit peu cher
c'est sûr c'est du neuf mais comme
disent nos artisans français le prix
s'oublie la qualité reste
à moins de meetic
bon un peu d'eau tout au début c'est
parce que je préfère mais c'est parti
[Musique]
bon super ok hasta luego
voilà voilà
bonjour en application de la loi je vais
faire un contrôle de vos papiers s'il
vous plaît c mais qu'est ce que vous
cherchez de la drogue des armes des
explosifs des armes à ça j'en ai pas
je n'en n'est rien non j'ai rien ils ont
ils ont du bon son dans leurs cahutes et
la musique à vienne
allez allez circulez aller adios
tu
ça va ils sont plus tôt
sont plutôt tranquilles
[Musique]
et
ben première étape de montagne
aujourd'hui à travers les collines du
chiapas et le début
une table encombrée 150
direction la forêt lacandone
mon thème sa présence
embouteillages
[Musique]
bonjour comment ça va
qu'est ce que je peux boire ici
1 qu'est ce que vous dites vous voulez
voir quoi qu'est ce que je peux boire
une bière non une bière non quelque
chose de sucré c'est pas limonade à une
citronnade si vous voulez ouais c'est
bien
chez moi
le malade web en limonade c'est bien
servi une citronnade ouais ouais il a eu
un effet ces détails à mexico
et limonades parfait
on est où ici
ban ki moon qui échappent à ce chien
parce
qu' à passe voilà je me fais engueuler
pardon pardon je m'excuse ou pas ah oui
oui ça c'est du française je suis venu
ici avec la mobylette donnez-moi trois
bonnes raisons pour visiter le chiapas
privant le lieu les gens et l'accueil
tous les gens du chiapas sont sympas
avec ceux qui viennent le visiter
alors au choix
tu te souviendras toujours du chiapas
il ya marqué mon voyage il m'a fait une
petite une petite pyramide
maya
[Musique]
c'est bon
la forêt tropicale et au tournoi est ici
se côtoient pas mal de communauté assez
différente forcément les unes des autres
parce que
éloignés 1
peu des gros bbc
qui pendant longtemps ont été quand même
considérer comme des citoyens de seconde
zone
[Musique]
allez
oui
[Musique]
et
bonsoir
quelqu'un
bonsoir il ya quelqu'un à
bienvenus je m'appelle henrique
moi c'est françois
enchanté
en train on est à l'intérieur en famille
toute la famille
bon ben c'est un accueil en bonne et due
forme je m'appelle françois françois
françois moyenne oui bien ok ok
ok signaler la mire l'italie
à
henrique qui est un des anciens de ce
petit village va je crois s'occuper de
son champ de maïs et m'a proposé de le
suivre
bon assez ouais ça ça va aller ça va pas
de problème ok
ok
quelle direction alors c'est par là par
là je te suis
ok ah ouais la machette et tout
ça craint pauvres
ah non mais moi je peux pas là
ok
c'est ça vient
il est vivant
non mais quand le spectre on s'y attend
pas
attention
un attaque mais
ou
caustiques la nature
[Musique]
alors
ça y est on est arrivé
c'est ce qu'on appelle la milpa un champ
de maïs
c'est un chant qui fait 2 hectares et
moi j'en cultive la moitié
le salon il t'appartient tu peux tu peux
le vent c'est
non on peut pas vendre la terre fait un
champ communautaire mais plusieurs
paysans à travailler dessus il ya des
paysans qui ont leur propre terre mais
nous non
tu es ce que tu utilise des pesticides
non
non non non jamais jamais de la vie nous
on pense que ça abîme la plante
en plus tu vois dans ce champ par
exemple en plus du maïs on cultive des
courges des yuccas et de la papaye la
papaye 7e en ce cas là ça prend tout
et après tu le manges c'est pour ça que
nous on n'utilise pas de pesticides pour
que les plantes est bonne
tu as raison moi aussi je pense la même
chose tu veux me filer un coup de main
mais attends rien
tout fait rire vous ferrez a hérité
en fait tu veux que je bosse quoi et
voilà le rendement avec moi
mais quel boulot pour faire
bah oui c'est comme ça qu'on travaille
nous asséner ses trop grand
au tout à l'égout la bonne
il s'est barré m'a foutu raza
il m'a mis un singe dans les bras une
banane et il s'est barré
[Musique]
le monde
le monde selon ma mobylette
[Musique]
doit françois avec le mali ce qu'on
cultive
on fait aussi de la farine c'est avec
cette farine que ma femme fait la
tortilla
voilà assez bon quand ça gonfle as tu as
you
well as bien gonflés alors montre moi
ta tak tak tarder comme on fait ma femme
ok voilà tu fais comme elle
[Rires]
ouais
venez ici les enfants vous allez bien
manger ce soir c'est tentant françois
qui fait la cuisine
maintenant tu la pause sont brûlés tu
l'achètes sur le feu
ces temps en temps tue la retourne non
on la retourne ou non tu vas y retourner
la
halle est mort d'ailleurs
[Musique]
elle va pas monter plus celle là la
prime à
aller tu veux en faire une autre non non
non non non non basta
ou non un désastre par jour ça suffit
maintenant on va manger un plat qu'on
mange souvent le soir chez nous les la
colonne c'est la crème de maïs
du maïs
très bien gracias
tu trouves que c'est bon on
a ouai
mais henrique qu'est ce que ça veut dire
être la colonne
lacombe dernis
être là qu on donne ça veut dire
continuer à parler le maya et vivre dans
la jungle c'est ça être la colonne tu
voyages un peu toi ou tu as voyages et a
déjà été à mexico mexico
mexico j'aime pas non il ya trop de
pollution et dernière fois j'avais les
yeux qui piquaient
au bout d'une semaine j'ai dit allez on
rentre
[Musique]
oui
alors
au j'ai appris quelques mots deux ans la
colonne tollé chez lafleur merci
beaucoup allez bonne chance bon bah je
reprends la route j'étais bien ici hein
[Musique]
il
je
muchos de la sas
[Musique]
al alam
vu ce qui m'attend
sur les 50 prochains kilomètres où ça
montre vraiment vraiment vraiment
et c'est ça aussi davantage de la
mobylette c'est qu'on peut la mettre
partout je vais m'offrir un petit tour
en transport collectif
non cela mais là tu me il va falloir de
l'aide
les gars vous êtes fort au fola soulevez
là
[Musique]
l'accès
il va me falloir de l'aide légale
je sais pas comment on va l'apporter
ouais mais attend
tout seul je vais avoir du mal
à temps excuse moi un mec
à temps ouais
ok - bienne à temps
[Musique]
parfait elle fecteau voir les gamins il
y en a 1 2 3
5 6 7 et 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
ans les 19 là pour instaurer un des gaz
[Musique]
et comment tu t'appelles françois
françois françois francisco
[Musique]
tétouan à tous
tonio
enchantée et tonio
voilà moi avec la moto je passais par là
moi je passais ans
en première je m'étais deux heures
[Musique]
d'abord bien sûr mon amiga c'est
vraiment ça
c'est physique fisico allez lire
une banane
ce plan
surtout
[Musique]
c'est bon
allez
patience et bonne continuation avec
muchas gracias
et cette petite incompréhension
en fait avec le chauffeur j'ai paniqué
je pensais être ce qui me on s'est mal
compris je pensais être sur une route
goudronnée et je suis pas en fait à la
vérité je suis pas du tout aux bons
endroits
non mais je comprends pas parce que
j'aurais pas dû descendre lui offrir il
repart aussi
qu'est ce qui fait chuter je croyais
qu'on était arrivé
j'ai rien compris
[Musique]
pour
à 2500 mètres d'altitude san cristobal
c'est très très très jolie ville qui fut
fondée par les espagnols 16e siècle a
aussi été la plus importante des civils
prise d'assaut en 94 par les troupes
baptiste
les temps changent
c'est aujourd'hui devenu une ville très
touristique
[Musique]
allez je vais pas m'endormir
la patate 1
[Musique]
avec meetic
c'est un gros mélange en fait musique
des andes tee shirt du che keffieh
palestinien
zapata le commandant marcos à bas la
fameuse
fameuse cagoule bois toute façon tous
les guerriers rose du monde sont là on
les a tous à bas la vraie la ja lie à la
totale
voilà les marchands du temple sont
toujours là ils ont récupéré le truc
ghotbi un bon business
zapata marcos et good business si oui
vous vendez acquis aux touristes surtout
aux touristes aux américains à tous ceux
qui visitent la ville
on en vend beaucoup ah ouais quand vous
les vendez vous donner de l'argent au
mouvement où ça rien à voir non pas du
tout les bénéfices sont pour la boutique
business ouais
c'est la bonne ambiance
c'est bon ça se mange comme ça ouais
avec quoi du parc en panne
avec ça je veux pas mais tout faymann
à temps
plus ma masse qu'est ce que tu me donnes
mec
masse toujours masse c'est toujours plus
à grâces f
[Musique]
non c'est bon - ouais non plus super bon
je peux fouet ben voilà
bah
sont-ce alain
salas aïe aïe
vous faites ça depuis longtemps monsieur
maintenant ça fait 3 ans 3 ans et avance
avant je travaillais dans une fabrique
de sucre 1
mais maintenant c'est fini je suis à la
retraite et comment on fait pour avoir
un emplacement vous l'achetez sa wii
l'emplacement on l'achète et à qui on
l'achète on l'achète au syndicat
assez bien organisé et ça va on gagne sa
vie en faisant ça c'est pas mal en une
journée je gagne entre 10 et 5 euros
d'accord c'est pas mal quand on sait que
le salaire moyen est de à peu près je
crois dans les 200 euros est ce que vous
êtes déjà trompé sur la couleur à ce que
vous avez déjà fait une bêtise grosse
bêtise non non non allez une fois je
suis sûr non non jamais non voilà ok
bon bah voilà
chez les chaps nickel
[Musique]
[Rires]
bon eh ben il n'est pas encore cinq
heures l'heure à laquelle normalement la
pluie tombe j'entends le tonnerre
gronder et je pense que je suis bon pour
une bonne sauce et donc mieux vaut
prévoir que subir et me voilà vêtu tel
un vaquero
prêt à affronter
une pluie tropicale
[Musique]
j'arrive maintenant à la garrucha qui
est un village
où peut-être même on peut dire un camp à
baptiste qui se trouve donc au sud du
chiapas
pas très loin du guatemala le mouvement
zapatiste sa mouvements issus du
soulèvement des paysans pour le droit à
la terre
parce qu'il ya encore une quinzaine
d'années
leavey dans des conditions
digne du servage
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
wallace dos
je m'appelle françois
vous venez d'où de
de france
tu peux rencontrer des gens des gens de
votre organisation on va voir passer moi
votre passeport à 6 6 et 6 passes pas
[Musique]
c'est bon allez attendre à l'intérieur
du camp ok merci beaucoup je passe par
ici
ok autre chose que la science
vraiment tout est vraiment toute
l'imagerie révolutionnaire national
portrait de
déminer aux la pâte ils ont une église
quand même
il ya le terrain de basket qui est assez
génial parce que même de même les
panneaux les paniers de basket son aaa
avec les fidji l'étoile zapatistes ça
c'est pas mal quand même
d'ailleurs les fiestas ici
ça doit donner un peu
[Musique]
ces bons suivez moi on va vous recevoir
à ok la saxe
[Musique]
merci
bonjour bonjour
est ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer de
façon générale qu'est ce que c'est que
le le mouvement zapatiste
nous sommes l'armée zapatiste de
libération nationale
s'est soulevée il ya quinze ans pour
reprendre de force les terres qu'ils
nous avaient été volés par les riches
propriétaires
les meilleures parcelles appartenait
même parfois à des étrangers
on les a reprises de force car c'était
notre droit
comment ça se passe concrètement avec
l'autorité avec le gouvernement mexicain
on n'a quasiment pas de contact avec le
gouvernement
c'est un mouvement clandestin est ce
qu'on peut dire ça
on porte la cagoule face aux caméras
pour que le monde entier se souviennent
qu'il ya encore quinze ans pour le
gouvernement mexicain on était
considérés comme des sous-hommes est ce
que vous pouvez me parler de
l'organisation de ce village
on travaille dans quatre directions
l'éducation car beaucoup de paysans de
cette région ne parle pas mexicain mais
des langues locales comme le celta loup
le sceau de cl
il y à aussi la santé et l'agriculture
la plupart des gens ici vivent du maïs
et de temps en temps on intervient aussi
dans le domaine de la justice qu'on aide
les gens dans leurs démarches
le mouvement s'appelle aphatie ce dont
vous vous réclamez de zapata quelle est
la corrélation avec ski c'est avec sa
patte à
ses les mêmes racines on demande de la
terre et la liberté
auliac en talons comme il s'est vraiment
passé
on des primaires rmn
thomas cook a testé
les piliers
et la plupart elle est souvent dominés
balle
bon alors voilà
le dortoir des zapatistes
c'est très simple j'ai un lift et avec
des bancs
c'est ultra rudimentaire ce soir hier
électricité donc c'est à la bougie il
paraît qu'il ya des rares qui courent
sur les murs la nuit ça j'aime pas ça du
tout avis à tous les altermondialistes
qui ont envie de s'engager dans la lutte
aux côtés des zapatistes
voilà ce que vous aurez voilà ce qui
vous attend
pour dormir
c'était des arriérés des rats pendant la
nuit
perfect mouchès gracias
[Musique]
hockey adios
gracieuse de gracias gracias a dios
ok
non
ça c'est un chant
qui a été repris par les zapatistes et
qui appartenait à une grosse famille et
macario qui travaillent aujourd'hui
dessus maintenant c'est un champ
communautaire et macario quand il était
gamin déjà travaillé sur ses terres mais
pour un patron il a une super des galbas
cariou
c'est pas qui c'est qui lui fait ses ses
fringues mais sont nickels
tu veux goûter
ça te plaît c'est du maïs du pot sol
acpo sol ça oui assez du maïs est vrai
qu'avec de l'eau tout simplement oui
conagua ouais c'est ça
tu sais faire une pause comme ça
discutait avec un étranger on n'aurait
pas pu le faire à l'époque des patrons à
6 heures on était au champ et ça
rigolait pas tu es plus tranquille - 30
kg
non seulement on est plus tranquille
mais la différence c'est que maintenant
on travaille pour nous tous ce qu'on
cultive nous appartient on n'est pas
beaucoup plus riche mais au moins on
mange à notre faim et on sait que nos
enfants auront plus tard des terres à
cultiver
et ça ça change tout ma carrière
gracias un bonne continuation ouais toi
aussi adios
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà allez les gars
finie la sieste
au bonjour monsieur
combien de litres ça va je sais pas
une pme comme ça qu'on met ses 10
[Musique]
à fond
mais ça donne quoi
une bouteille de tequila et tequila
ouais c'est la 2 qu'il avait il va
mettre des tequilas dans nos réservoirs
mais elle est bonne votre essence bien
sûr qu'elle est bonne
paris ré
et pour aller plus vite vers lens on a
ça oui hall et merci à mes gosses
[Musique]
je suis à ariha gars
arriaga toujours dans l'état du chiapas
mais je suis descendu dans les plaines
et arriaga
a la particularité d'être une des
premières villes
avec une gare
après la frontière avec le guatemala
ça n'existe plus les trains de passagers
au mexique il ya uniquement des trains
de marchandises il n'empêche qu'il y a
toujours des passagers sur ses trains ce
sont tous les clandestins qui viennent
du guatemala principalement mais aussi
de toute l'amérique centrale pourra les
émigrés aux états unis est ici arriaga
il ya la maison des immigrants pour
essayer de donner un peu de réconfort à
ces types qui tentent l'aventuré
voilà
carlos hockey françois bienvenus entrée
au quai la sias vous avez beaucoup de
deux personnes fatiguées abîmé peut-être
ici tous les migrants arrivent malades
soit avec la grippe de la toux
ou des infections à l'estomac à cause de
l'eau qu'ils boivent dans la rivière
il ya aussi des femmes qui arrivent avec
des bébés donc nous on essaie de les
aider avec le peu de moyens qu'on a mais
bon le problème c'est qu'ici on n'a
vraiment pas grand chose
mais carlos il ya vous avez combien de
personnes qui restent là en moyenne il
ya combien de personnes ben pas moi on
enregistre environ 600 personnes
l'année passée on a eu environ 8000
personnes huit mille personnes c'est
énorme c'est là
le salon ça c'est la salle télé j'aime
bien technique des chaises
des chaises renversées ouais c'est là
qu'il se détende ouais qu'il se repose
un peu avant de repartir
[Musique]
ça fait peur d'entreprendre un voyage
comme ça non c'est pas vraiment le
voyage qui fait peur sont plutôt les
délinquants qui nous rackettent dans les
trains en fait
c'est vrai qu'on craint plus les
racketteurs que la police de
l'immigration
bonne chance bonne chance on dit en
français j'écris mon nom way in hong lei
c'est bien mais si tu mets ton nom la
vie à l'excès bonne continuation et
bravo pour pour le boulot
et
oui
bon allez moi je quitte les montagnes du
cha passe pas très loin du pacifique
maintenant et je vais dans l'état du
croire ac cas du roi cas dans la ville
de fujita eba
[Musique]
je te décides un petit coeur en petits
qu'eux on colle à 100
merci
merci merci beaucoup merci mon chéri
sap à l'envi ressort à la mort la mort
il ya que ça mais c'est tout il ya tout
seul bon aller très bien
[Musique]
c'est pas en france qu'on fait d accueil
comme ça dans les stations-service 1 tu
peux me déposer en centre-ville
au centre oui il centre
en auto stop tu
sais si tu es
[Musique]
bon je fini en beauté j'y arrive bientôt
au pacifique
j'ai une auto stoppeuse
je suis très connu ici tu sais oui très
connu
et pourquoi
je suis une actrice
ça c'est très intéressant
avec ge est une actrice
très célèbre une actrice porno ah bon
actrice porno aïe aïe aïe
bon les gars
non mais là c'est trop
tu sais mon chéri que je suis très
chaude
bah ouais j'imagine oui
non
tu me fait le coup de la panne
je vais pas lui faire le coup de la
panne non c'est
bon
alors très bien
mon auto stoppeuse qu'une actrice porno
veux me présenter une copine dans mon
auto stoppeuse
aulas
wallace andes
céline a une copine
enchanté je m'appelle françois c'est oui
bien bonjour bienvenue là
c'est un salon d'esthétique que
l'esthétique oh oui
d'accord ok un salon de coiffure mais
aussi un lieu de prévention contre le
sida
on distribue des préservatifs à nos
clients monaco c'est une association
c'est une association ou s'occupe aussi
des transsexuels ici dans l'office ici
harouchi tan il n'ya pas transsexuels il
ya des transgenres adéquat comme de
travestis ou filles de travestis des
lesbiennes des bisexuels d'accord
des homosexuels des hétéros
un peu de tout
alors j'aurais dû prendre des fleurs
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui je me rends
à une invitation chez elle viendra que
j'ai prise en stop hier elle aurait fait
partie d'une communauté assez
particulière ici à fouchy tan communauté
d'hommes
qui sont pas travesti tout simplement
pour les fêtes et qui vivent vraiment
ici en tant que femme
[Musique]
au bout
salut
bonjour
comment ça va très bien je suis en plein
boulot ouais je fais de la couture
j'habite ici avec comme la papa la maman
oui avec mon père et ma mère
ah ouais oui c'est quand j'ai été reine
l'ena de rennes dans une fête au mot
félicitations
tout rose comme ça
on dire aux grands palaces ah
[Musique]
oui elle est très gai ma maison en
traversant ton quartier c'est comme un
quartier assez populaire
assez dur est ce que vous êtes bien
accepté ici
ici on considère que c'est une chance
d'avoir un travesti dans sa fameuse
nous les mots chess comme on nous
appelle harouchi talent quand les
enfants sur marié et qu'il quitte la
famille on reste à la maison pour
s'occuper des parents quand ils sont
vieux et seuls et nous les mooch s on
reste avec eux jusqu'à la fin mal
viens je vais te montrer la radio c'est
juste là
ces pratiques
bonjour à tous vous êtes en direct avec
les intrépides les présentatrices les
plus canons de la bande fm et on est
ensemble pour deux heures d'antenne
well mais comment tu fais toi pour avoir
des seins aussi ferme
on a
même ici t'as pas un gramme de cellulite
c'est pas juste
tu dois avoir un secret
je suis à la trace les intrépides
après leur séquence radio elles m'ont
donné rendez vous dans un parc de la
ville où elles font une distribution
paraît-il pour la jeunesse de
préservatifs et de tracts faut que
j'aille voir ça
juniors 1 tiens un préservatif pour toi
abad accord quelle brute
non il n'en veut pas elle ne veut pas
celui qui aime se protège vous faites
une bonne équipe pour les filles c'est
bien bien travaillé bien par maman ces
importants travaux allemande à moi je
dois y aller
[Musique]
m
c'est le hasard je savais pas que
j'allais tomber sur une plage comme ça
mais le décor est idyllique
donc ça y est c'est fait j'ai rallié
l'atlantique au pacifique
[Musique]
bon c'est ici que se termineront voyagé
au mexique
mais parmi tous les gens que j'ai
rencontrés sur la route il ya quand même
quelqu'un qui à mon avis
aurait grand besoin de cette mobylette
je profite encore un peu de la plage et
puis je vais reprendre la route en sens
inverse et je vais aller lui donner
où
[Musique]
il
qui
[Musique]
nous
on
j'ai décidé de revenir à la casa del
migrante et à la maison des migrants
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai été quand
même assez
ému
par le boulot qui se fait là-bas je
trouve que c'est quelque chose de très
très bien mdd tous ces mecs qui prennent
courageusement la route
[Musique]
je me suis dit que c'était une bonne
chose
d'aller leur offrir sept modules est ni
carlos
bienvenue monsieur comment ça va
monsieur hâte après voilà
carlos
bien voir
creo je trouve que tu fais un très bon
travail
travail trop travaille
alors comme moi je vais en france moi je
repars en france
et je souhaite proposer la moto net la
mobylette pour la maison des migrants tu
veux me la donner oui je te la donne
pour la maison des migrants merci merci
c'est bien
voilà c'est sûr que ça va nous aider ça
peut servir ouais c'est
alors parfait
villahermosa elle primo que j'ai mis sur
la moto m ça c'est les zapatistes la
connaissent le début au chiapas ça c'est
les sa
baisse à des modes chesnet
rocher talent salut carlos
allaient
juste le rendra et encore merci
d'ennahda d'ennahda est là et continue
bien le boulot allez salut carlos
[Musique]